new satellite images of the zapparesian
nuclear power plants and the roofs of
reactors three and four no signs of
explosives on them but they could be too
small to see with these pictures say our
experts overnight ukrainians were issued
with these instructions how to evacuate
a radiation Zone after this warning from
their president
now we have information from our
intelligence that the Russian troops
have placed objects resembling
explosives on the roof of several power
units of the zaparesia nuclear power
plant but
stimulate an attack on the plant perhaps
they have some other scenario Ukraine
says Vladimir Putin could be encouraged
by the world's muted response to this
act of mass destruction and now planning
another one at zapparesia Western
intelligence has no doubt that Russia
blew the dam at kahovka but today Russia
turned events on their head
the situation around zapparisha nuclear
power plant is quite tense because the
threat of sabotage by the key of regime
is indeed great the sabotage can be
catastrophic in its consequences the
Kiev regime has repeatedly demonstrated
its Readiness to stop at nothing in
Russian hands the nuclear plant is a
brooding Menace across the now drained
Reservoir the governor of the plant's
Town who stays in touch with people
there told us Russians haven't fled the
area but residents remain alarmed
as for the number of troops there are no
changes the zaparesia nuclear power
plant is still used as a military base
the stress level at the station is quite
tense
the nuclear Watchdog the iaea says it
seen no evidence of Foul Play at the
plant but can't say for sure without
more access ever since Russians took the
plant it's been a source of constant
anxiety for ukrainians they are taking
no chances running drills to prepare for
the worst afraid the Russians are
capable of anything if the war continues
to go against them
Dominic waghorn Sky News Odessa
[Music]